la vie nous a été donnée il y a un milliard d'années
qu'en avons-
nous fait  tourner dans
cette ville, j'adore pouvoir
explorer cette ville et je pense que d'une certaine
manière, le fait que nous étions tous si
fatigués et en décalage horaire et hors de notre
élément a vraiment ajouté à la sorte de
désorientation du personnage
ce qu'il y a dedans  ne sois pas paranoïaque avec moi d'
accord tu me fais confiance n'est-ce pas
ouais j'ai toujours envie que ce
film commence à un autre endroit et l'asie
était parfaite et sur le scénario j'ai toujours
mis taipei parce que j'ai opté pour le cinquième
élément 20  il y a des années et j'adore la ville
le sentiment des gens et le plus drôle
c'est qu'à la fin nous nous retrouvons dans l'
hôtel que j'ai connu il y a 20 ans
à paris ils ont eu cette idée folle de
faire passer la voiture dans le sens
opposé sur le chemin  à l'hobarty
qui est le  coeur de paris nous avons filmé à
la salvador la plus belle
université de paris la
sorbonne est une des plus anciennes université
de paris
et tu as toutes ces grandes connaissances
et tu arrête l'école très tôt je fais des
films et je suis maintenant je fais un film
à propos de la connaissance et je ne fais que détruire
leurs connaissances et en fait, le dernier
jour, vous ne pouvez même pas le reconnaître, alors
bombardez, c'est tout simplement incroyable